salut youtube et salue maxime salut
salut le tchad salut tout le monde donc
maxime déjà un grand grand grand grand
grand merci de venir apparente un jour
de repos discutent avec nous faire une
interview avec plaisir et a toujours
l'air comme toujours de bonne humeur à
fond au taquet et je te sens en forme en
plus là je sais pas je te sens bien ça
va ouais après bon il ya des ya des
hauts et des bas toujours dans une
compétition de trois semaines mais dans
l'ensemble ça va
après il ya le seul point négatif c'est
qu'on va dire que dans toutes les
parties y ait eu des yeah il ya eu des
moments maîtrisé dans toutes les parties
de tailles jusqu'à maintenant t'as pas
tout le temps était sûr de toi
ouais enfin toutes les parties longues
déjà sauf peut-être la deuxième contre
jacquot villa pour le coc était surtout
une très bonne défense de sa part même
si même si j'aurais pu sans doute faire
mieux à certains moments donc ça c'était
c'était la berlinoise dans la partie
dans la partie longue mais
ok donc tu te sens tu te sens en forme
sinon ce qu'il part en contrôle savent
que tes calculs sont pas aussi précis
que tu le souhaiterez où c'est à
l'analyse quand tu rentres que c'est
carrément pendant la partie que tu te
sens un peu ça dépend mais par exemple
le premier match et notre daniel amouny
j'ai senti tout de suite que certaines
positions je les avais mal négociées à
partir de très gros avantage donc bon
forcément le fait que je joue est dit
dans ce match que c'est le respect
c'était pas très avantageuse forcément
il ya toujours des petits relâchements
qu'ils sont possibles
après konkobo laine comme par exemple
moment où je le laisse s'en sortir au
40e quand je les laisse faire
pour ces huit ouais ça j'ai vu
malheureusement après avoir joué mon
coup à jouer tour des six états vu le
truc après non mais tour de suisse un
bon coup mais c'est juste plus altier
mauvais oui c'est à prévessin canton
chêneraie mais tu as joué assez vite les
deux coups dangereux que tu as fait
tourner six baies 5 assez lente pour des
styles relativement dit et après tout
des sables du temps sur des cinq genres
sept minutes
excuse moi il suffit que en face le truc
pour quel téléphone qui sonne et que
j'ai pas eue sur silencieux
désolé mais l'intéressé continue et
ouais d'ailleurs je vais faire la même
si jamais ça c'est la poisse donc des
cinq mois j'ai mis sept huit minutes
en fait je voulais jouer pouces et 5 et
puis je me suis dit des cinq sacs
gagnent en fait j'ai vu j'ai vu les
couacs et ses 8 j'ai vu les tours prend
à 5 mai bon juste au moment où je joue
j'ai vu qu'ils avaient tous à 8
voilà et puis la deuxième c'est surtout
l'ouverture que j'ai mal maîtrisée il ya
eu un mouvement où j'ai joué trop vite
où j'ai joué sept et je suis obligé de
rentrer dans la finale qu'ils ont
certaines bonnes âmes mais un petit peu
un petit peu désavantageuse après il ya
kovalenko bon ça on va pas revenir sur
l'échiquier mais il n'a pas forcément
super bien géré la
non ouais non en fait par contre c'est
plutôt joli
ce que je devais faire enfin mon sens
gpb gym ne peut vérifier ses hauts-lieux
de recettes
bon ya pas de la partie mais alors n'est
pas en a pas on n'avait pas prévu un ep
après-midi pour le secteur ouais je vais
juste dire un donc vos lieux de recettes
food et 7 kgs c4 maintenant recettes et
idées 6 et c'est là je m'étais arrêté
parce qu'en fait ils menacent bessette
et f7 puisque le food et cette emprise
et là maintenant pousser 8 donc tu as
l'impression d'avoir perdu deux temps
d'avoir mis le coeur des blancs des six
langues ou baisser au cours des huit
attaques le cahier des six fou prend
cette histoire prend 2,6 et tu es games
mais pour ceux qui ont regardé avec
l'ordi nous ça après qu avec fable quand
on a revu la partie on l'a vu aussi pas
dû comme on s'était parlé on a regardé
quand tu veux mes lordi le il le montre
à cette variante là et donc du coup
cette histoire de forme ça revient par
la suite ou pas tu vert pour un tournoi
ça tu arrive parfois d'être un peu comme
ça de se sentir semis en dedans et après
oui après ba s'était pas catastrophique
non plus n'était pas du tout que la fin
de la subtile cup
j'avais quand même eu le temps de me
reposer
pas mal à paris donc je sens que j'ai
rebooster un peu mon énergie même si
j'ai pas pu faire au terrain de sports
que que je le souhaitais j'ai planté un
petit peu et puis bon je sens que je
sens que ça va mieux même si le plus dur
commence avec encore et 6 et 3 trop gros
match à remporter pour la qualif
alors on est d'accord que l'objectif
c'est d'aller en finale
là une fois que tu seras en finale à la
rigueur face j'ai pas envie de dire que
c'est anecdotique 2 gagne ou pas mais on
va dire que maintenant mais en fait une
fois qu'on en finisse avec georgia tu la
gagnes mais voilà oui c'est lui le plus
important c'est on va dire que le wifi
l'objectif avoué de pour toi maxime
c'est d'aller en finale après une fois
que tu en voilà
bon ok c'est de la gagner on est
d'accord mais donc avant de parler de la
suite du tournoi j'aurais aimé bien
revenir avec toi sur les départage du
coup puisqu'on à ce qu'on a suivi là où
on a le plus vibrer j'ai envie de dire
et surtout surtout sur les deux
premières parties en fait tout le match
était assez intéressant donc bon alors
les la première où je me suis retrouvé
rapidement moins bien je me suis planté
très vite heureusement il n'a pas été
très précis dans l'angle est la première
partie longue
bref la deuxième partie donc par contre
j'ai plutôt bien joué
à un moment il s'est planté il s'est
retrouvé dans une finale très très
compliqué et j'en donne à ce moment là
il a défendu de façon quasi impeccable
et ça me j'avais l'impression que
c'était gagnant devant l'échiquier salle
et à peut-être mais j'ai pas je vais pas
trouver j'ai pas m'amuser depuis mais ça
va vraiment leurs gagnants
c'est mon ordi eu de but oui donc alors
attendez cette partie on peut quand même
y revenir parce qu'en fait tu étais donc
chatwood pendant la partie
j'étais dans le chatt reach ouais alors
il ya un truc incroyable c'est à dire
qu'un moment donné je regarde la liste
des pseudos des gens qui sont là pendant
la deuxième partie et qui joue
adventure je fais un petit rebond tu
vois je me dis il se passe quoi je
clique sur mv de chasse et je te jure il
y aura les gens il ya des centaines de
personnes peuvent te prouver le no fake
c'était vraiment ton pseudo qui étaient
connectés ouais ouais ça ça pouvait être
laurent vérat et on a en a on a gueulé
triche triche triche de partout maxime
écoute live on est et on est et on était
à deux doigts de dénoncer à la fidh et
tout après on s'est dit bon on va quand
même aider le joueur français donc on a
regardé à fond alors dit après et avant
dans la cour on disait qu'on disait sur
le premier coup de la ligne en fait mais
bon si jamais il écoute pendant la
partie
mais du coup c'est ton manager don qui
suivent et qui suit les images imagine
un doux cas heureusement il n'y a pas
d'accès à tous qui est matos
électronique
du coup c'était pour la petite de petits
trucs marrants en fait on se voyait
vraiment été très chaud pendant cette
partie c'est bien apprendre où il a joué
la grave et où on sait maintenant qu on
l'expliqué associe bon du coup c'était
pour le moins peu plaisanterie on
revient sûr du tout la sphère
particulier partage où il ya un moment
en fait je peux tu peux te poser des
questions directement sur quelques coups
moi qui m'ont qui vont interpeller wave
asie bon j'ai avancé un peu la première
du départage
ainsi si c'est la première de sites web
donc j'avance un peu et j'avais une
première question du coût et chic yen
après des 5
ouais non mais j'ai complètement
sous-estimé dessins que ça m'arrive
souvent dans ce genre de position lui
est en fait je voulais jouer jusqu'à
hier cinq prises prises et puis en fait
là j'ai vu ces 4 f 4 4 et ça ça va pas
j'avais une partie très similaires quand
les hommes à londres où je m'en étais
sorti un peu par miracle c'est pour ça
que cinq ce que c'est la question qu'on
se posait donc la réponse mais ça c'est
pas bon et ça c'est très dangereux
dire ok mais en fait tu vois juste moi
je suis pas un spécialiste de la deûle à
grünfeld de ses ex tructures là on
connaît pas trop et du coup on sait pas
parce qu avec l'ordinateur en fait on
est d'accord que tout à des évaluations
mais ça veut rien dire noël mot non plus
nous que ça va quand même plus souvent
pour moi lorsqu'on fait cavalier à 5
geslin préfet j'arrive j'allais vraiment
à juger moi personnellement quand ça
concerne a pas mais j'ai eu l'impression
contre ça arrivait contre magnus deux
fois donc theus cavaliers qui se perdent
un peu et là dans cette partie ça a
donné l'impression qui s'était un peu
perdu aussi donc voilà mais après
c'était un peu différent dans cette
partie bombée du coup ça va je suis sûr
que ça va c'est une ouverture lou tu
prends des risques
consciemment ou ça peut mal se passer
quand tu donnes le simple forcément faut
toujours être prêt sienni parfois tu
peux pas tu peux pas l'être autant que
wall et ux donc oui ça peut ça peut
souvent donner cette impression là mais
demandez pas n'en fait pas foncièrement
une mauvaise ouverture donc les donc non
mais c'est pas du tout un mauvais coup
c'était vivre pour comprendre en fait
comme comme je sais que tu mets toujours
le cavalier sur à 5 et comme tu as comme
on est spectateur enfin je commande
beaucoup de thé pas je me pose toujours
cette question en fait pourquoi est donc
là dont moi pas tu nous as donné la
réponse quoi du tout c'est pour remonter
du coup parce que ça intéresse donc
c'est ça et avait peur de af445 du coup
on saura pour les prochains tours ouais
ok donc du coup ça alors tu veux dire si
tu veux arrêter un moment dans deux
heures
et là c'est un peu normal
[Musique]
ces quatre fous ces deux dames c'est 7e
hélas après des systèmes ce sens il faut
trop j'hésitais en fait entre je voulais
d'abord jouer aux dames à 3 mai puis
ensuite j'ai été attiré par d'un match 5
qui avec l'idée aussi d'avoir des fous
g4 mais malheureusement ça marche pas je
pense que damages 509 être décisive dans
la partie ouest alma troillet s'il ya
quelque chose de précis un matelas c'est
ce que je voulais faire à la base
food et 4 j'avais un peu peur que la
dame soit un peu mal place soit un peu
trop éloigné de l'action mais c'est sans
doute bon à prendre des pincettes mais
c'est sans doute pas si grave
alors je sais pas toi ce que tu avais
vus nous n'avez variante là on était là
à toi mais ok seul bien quand c'est le
bordel quoi je sais pas quoi faire au
moins ça n'avait pas l'air écrasant
devant l'échiquier mais peut-être qu'il
faut pas laisser les c'est la dame
s'installerait fils quand même un tour
aussi sous quelque chose voir infliger
quatre maintenant
l'aiac et aux 5 je sais pas exactement
mais bon forcément céder position très
délicate à jouer peut-être après fou
décote va prendre dans lesquels jouent
en fuite
même si ça fait peur des fameuses non
c'est délicat comme position ça c'est
sûr c'est peut-être ça aussi qui t'a
fait changer d'avis pour le père match 5
oui bah j'avais peur que la dame soit
soit hors du jeu c'est pour ça que je de
match 5 mai après peut-être que damas
trois c'est pas vrai non plus pour moi
j'ai pas j'ai pas regardé mais devant
mener devant l'échiquier
une fois que la position se dégrader
après après x 4 en plus ses plus fins et
pas forcé forcé mais c'est plus ou moins
feintes à jouer tous les meilleurs coups
en fait là il a été impressionnant bond
aux basses et par la suite il a été
vraiment impressionnant donc là oui j'ai
raté tour des 5
lieu saint où a lui aussi mais oui
j'aurais dû jouer dans les cinq sets
même si je suis moins bien donc ok mais
là de toute façon ce qu'il a fait c'est
très naturel aussi
oui c'est assez logique là bon ok g
dames à saintes où ma fille qui me
permet de me battre bon j'y arrivais
tour 8 mais bon de toute façon on
pensait qu'ils allaient pas le trouver
en direct toi c'était quoi ta sensations
pendant pendant la partie tu vois tu va
le trouver et des qui réfléchit je sais
qu'il va le trouver
ouais assure f3 dam des traces et tout
de suite nul et dont la position semble
appelée autre chose donc du coup de
tours 8
tu envisages puisque sa part la menace
de maths après tel plan d après c'est
pas évident à trouver mais ça se trouve
ouais là tu peux plus rien faire je
croyais pas non mais j'ai très bien
défendu j'ai joué tous les meilleurs
coups je pense à jouer les programmes et
je pensais m'en sortir voilà le problème
c'est roigé cette dame ou sept ans elle
se tiendrait jamais genre s'y joue b 5 à
je pensais qu'ils allaient jouer h 3
puis un moment au bon moment d'amd 8 un
truc du genre ou d'un match 4 ouais je
pensais que ça ça pouvait pas tenir sa
ouais donc l'aune du coup nos dames 6
est le problème c'est qu'après dame des
eats est obligé de venir en aide cette
situation arrange de cette dame e set
sellal histoire hélas il a été
impressionnant il a trouvé la suite tout
référendum ses sept tours détours vers
assez fort parce que tu peux plus faire
et d'hommes de cette dame de hockey
d'homme c'est un bon là j'ai pas joué
tour a écrite puisque ce sont absolument
sans espoir genre décède tour dès 8 h
troc aux caisses et c'est fini
complètement tour j'ai 5 c c'est encore
plus finissent mais seulement s'il
trouve d'un petit louis triaud c'est nul
ouais mais il a trouvé mais bon motif
préfère tenter ta chance sur un truc
comme
quoi ouais bah oui euh ouais en plus
surtout rejet 5 donc il ya des lignes
quand même assez chaude par exemple sur
tous les cinq
admettons bon tu joues automatique tour
g1 108 sur tour des ceintures comme ces
huit là tu te prends pour ces cinq des
sept dames d'être à ce qui est pas très
dur dans le tour des cinq mais bon ouais
il avait bu trop de temps il ya des
écueils sur tours d2 pareil ces dames
c'est tour c5 et là tu as peut-être
peut-être tu perds avec les blancs parce
que tu attaques là et sur valverde va me
prendre et deux non et non et c'est
encore mieux le monde pas sûr
as-tu soir durant la réception
c'est ça ouais euh non tu récupères à
7,1 mais bon bref c'est mieux pas déjà
nul c'était voilà mais oui à trèbes a
bien joué mais ils havre où il a été la
chercher
donc du coup tu te retrouve mené au
score était dans l'obligation de gagner
le match
le match retour dray et tu joues avec
les blancs ouais tu joues avec les
blancs donc et tu rentres tu joues une
italienne et on a l'impression que à la
sortie pouvaient ils jouent les boîtes
m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils jouent ça
bon j'ai pas forcément tous bien négocié
la ligne finale wpt est assez mais je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils jouent ligne
aussi foncièrement risque est en fait je
pensais qu'il allait jouer un peu comme
il a joué au contraire dans les autres
parties de partage donc il a joué cette
variante là
voilà dame prend des trois est là en
fait tu es obligé de rentrer dans une
position guère web après égal 1 la
finale wpt est égal mais bon je pensais
que ça a joué j'ai assez mal négocié le
truc
j'avance un peu 1 1 et après tu peux
mais j'ai pas mais bon au moins j'ai
réussi à jouer vite et bon je sais que
c'est toujours un des credo à ce que je
jouais trop vite passé vite mais bon ça
ça a ses inconvénients ça aussi ses
avantages ça m'a permis comme de vie
mettre pas mal de pression dans cette
partie on en dise qu'une à bourg sur les
là il va compter sur la position poids
de ça mais oui quand tu gagnes on dit
que tu as joué vite que tu as mis la
pression et quand tu gagnes pas on dit
tu as joué trop vite tu vois ça ça
dépend du résultat c'est pour tous le
voir elle la bonne on n'est pas aussi
donc voilà mais là ce qui est clair pour
moi que si je jouais pas je vis de cette
partie jamais jours à gagner on ne sait
pas on a senti un premier tournant parce
que là franchement on était on était
bloqués mais fou prend 2 tu vas même qu
envisagée ce qu'on fait du bruit mais là
aussi qu'il faut comprendre un peu
l'esprit
bon alors en plus moi j'ai j'ai connu ce
genre de situation quand même des
proches de la qualif l'annulent te
suffit machin vont forcément tu es des
pensées parasites qui sa duc qui
viennent mais bon il faut pas tomber
dans les pièges et c'est ce que j'ai
bien fait ensuite en fin de match mais
vous prend 2 c'est pas du tout naturel
en meuse draw ouais non c'est sûr mais
après on s'est dit que c'était peut-être
un premier un premier tournant
non non et kg si c'est tellement naturel
et puis qui eux 5
comment tu veux la paix maintenant le
tournant c'est il faut toujours en fait
avoir une certaine limite dans des
simplifications et dans ce que tu
cherches à obtenir et je pense que le
premier tournant c'est fou quand quatre
portes alors pour vous c'était deuxième
du coup mais pourquoi c'est le premier
parce que prend 1,4 c'est vraiment pas
obligé ils auraient pu juste faire c'est
très spécial ouais j'aurais joué j'ai 30
ans et je veux dire j'aurais pajot kg
saint tout de suite
non nous on avait juste regarder pour
voir ce que ce que donnaient les changes
oui mais j'ai rempli par contre
foncièrement en fait joué à jouer kg 5
tout de suite je vais jouer roi g2b 4 à
4,6 gémeaux la possibilité foulée trois
échecs en gros je vais jouer de la même
chose que je veux s'il est 4 mai où il
la défense et bizarrement plus facile
enfin bizarrement avec la perte de fou
alors qu'avec les fous de couleurs
opposées salle est revenu bien je veux
dire c'est quand même très difficile de
blâmer c'est plus par la suite en fait
mais que je veux blâmer cette technique
qu'il a fait mais oui mais je pense
aussi et qu' il n'y à ce moment là il
s'est vu beau aussi ce qui est
compréhensible et ça a pu causer un
relâchement qui l'a fait prendre de
décisions un peu justement hâtives
donc j'ai six notamment fixé sur blanc
et ça a l'air de rien ça a l'air
complètement nul
mais c'est pas si simple et après des
quatre ça devient tout de suite plus
compliqué alors sur à cinq je pensais
que tours 2-2 ou à troyes aube
mais au tour b deux sur à 4 ha bon ak
peut-être non j'ai pas trahi la tour
d'un e
non ok à 5 peut-être juste à 3 alors
ouais échanger les pions ah bon c'est
peut être une réussite mais c'est pas
sûr 1 c'est pas des décisions si facile
et si nous le truc c'est surtout d'un
nom ça marche pas ici parce que tu joues
fou c5 v6 oui mais mais bon il ya
toujours enfin c'est ce qu'il a fait
c'était très naturel donc je veux dire
mais voilà je pense qu'aussi il s'est
relâché et au moment où l'asie
il s'est rendu compte que la situation
redevenait un peu compliqué donc calmés
temps après tour b2 et c est là qu en
fait difficile pour lui c'est juste
alors déjà il est moins bien autant même
si ça paraît rien et puis également en
fait la position est beaucoup plus
compliquée à des fins qu'on pourrait le
croire de prime abord ce à cause de
l'activité du fou mais évidemment c'est
beaucoup plus facile à défendre que par
exemple qu'il a défendue à la deuxième
partie longue
wemmel a dit avec la deuxième partie
longue il a eu le temps de s'adapter il
a du temps de comprendre qu'il allait
souffrir là il a cru qu'ils étaient à
95% qualifier et puis là il se rend
compte que c'est plus que 80 m
bon bah panique à bord quoi il a mis la
panique et là les deux coups qu'il a
fait fou des huit tours c'est cette
c'était spécial on avait pensé faille
qui vous tourner un homme et tour d'un
des cinq qu'est ce que tu fais venir
vous voulez passer par derrière un peu
ce qui se passait je suis comment ça se
passe msa rien d'évident cette position
peut-être s'éprend b5 apprend des 5 à 5
mais bon déjà tu donnes un pion
peut-être que tu revois pas probablement
assez d'activité mais c'est pas une
décision que tu veux prendre clairement
ouais bon ah ouais par contre c'est vrai
qu'il faut faire a sévi la pêcherie
karelia b à b x 5 aussi tu as des choses
comme ça
une transe et 6 tomber cette ou ces
quatre d'abord c4as est plus que chaud
là c'est peut-être déjà vu
du coup pas simple ouais pas simple mais
bon là du coup elle fout des huit tours
c'est cet été que c'est quand même un
peu triste non à tour 6-7 je pense que
c'est là un gros tournant dans cette
partie alors même si c'est sans doute
objectivement encore mieux ça devient de
plus en plus délicat et ça me laisse
faire ces 4 j'ai quand même un gros
faute aurait fait comment il s'est
repris à quatre agents seraient en jeu
c'est pas mal hier jean peut-être amené
le roi elle dame mais après c'est
toujours un peu tendu en fait ce qui se
passe c'est aussi mon clan serreau f3 de
tourbe et un tour h 1 h 5
c'est pour ça qu'il a joué tour c'est
cette chance c'est pour pouvoir je
devais 5 et puis mais bon je vais pas
laisser le temps j'ai joué c4 elle est
vraiment dans le dur déjà six des 5
ok c'est sans doute encore nulle en ça
c'est pas le souci mais là j'étais déjà
en moi c'était déjà du 50 50
mais si j'aurais peut-être jouera des
six là par contre à st croix c52 pas sûr
de ses positions là d'un autre côté je
les voyais pas de coups en fait je s'il
faut bouger à tour ces deux tours 7
du coup j'allais peut-être améliorer les
droits je sais pas trop comment un rêve
trop j'ai peut-être aux ouvrages 3 et 3g
4g ensuite s'ils jouent h5 roche troyat
le pion g6 cetera bon peut-être un petit
tour des 1
donc voilà je me trouvais pas trop de
coups mais d'un autre côté je sais pas
comment progresser quoi voilà tu te pas
sûr mais dans notre leur troisième côté
c'est plutôt pas mal parce que tu vas
pouvoir la jouer pendant 150 coût quoi
ouais bah oui non mais ben là c'est déjà
eu un un petit murale d'obtenir une
position comme ça donc aucun des six à
cinq tours b 5 tours des six tours prend
à 5 ans des six tours à 7
ouais mais jongleurs et à sang
le jeu des bureaux à b6 mais c'est ok
c'est pas facile comme coûts et par
contre si et quand même un détail
important je joue pas tout reprendre de
sat que je pense alors j'ai pas vérifié
mais en tout cas il faut plus y en a
quatre c'est très probablement nulle
cette finale avec le pian assiste c'est
très probablement gagnant c'est ce que
nous a dit fab
donc ça c'est qu'à une grande réussite
pour toi de ses idées c'est qu'à un
moment je vais jouer g4 il va être plus
ou moins forcé de jauge est simple
puisque si la sphère g5 roche 3g 4 h 5
je vais gagner
donc j'ai 5 h 5 et ensuite je vais jouer
le principe des deux faiblesses donc
soit ramené droit elle dame où je vais
soit ramené le droit à la loi pour
attaquer son voilà donc bref avec le
pire à quatre pense que c'est encore nul
il doit pouvoir doit figurer avec l'euro
encore donc voilà l'idée c'est sûr à 5
maintenant fouet cette tour premier set
ça des chances d'être gagnante genre ça
pour faire simple ouais ensuite x 4 f 3
et 4 donc la ci soit il a joué à chis g5
s'il n'a pas joué il va se prendre g53
g3 g4 et c'est la même chose
je vais essayer de rentrer avec le roi
soit vers f5 pour aller taper les
couleurs 80 suite je vais faire un petit
échec aux bandes noires en haut 6 et il
va devoir choisir jeu mettra le fond ces
quatre le rang 4 et le roi devra partir
d'un côté ou de l'autre est il que tu
vas gagnera ouais mais là c'est déjà dur
après roy et fils s'est passé une gaffe
1 et l'iedom j'avais vu rôder si ce qui
sans doute la seule chance mais bon
après ça doit être nul mais bon courage
m6 vous prend 2,7 bon
il sait pas peur c'est tout de suite que
le mal a été fait il a dû être à fond
quand j'ai joué food et 5e petits pièges
et c'est fini alors peut-être on passe
directement au bliss du coup ouais il ya
quelque chose que tu veux revoir le
rapide bon bah on passe on passe à la la
la partie tu as gagné du coup ouais
ouais donc du coup c'était on avait
répété ce qu'il a joué en 10 minutes
tu as été bon il a surpris qu'il change
son fusil d'épaulé par rapport à sa
réussite
on bosse tf1 c'est quand même une ligne
délicate à jouer et évidemment j'étais
mieux préparer cette fois-là donc non je
n'étais pas surpris du tout qui change
donc il a changé ses parents s'est
demandé s'il fallait pas faire b4
l'emportent
ouais on va pas se plaindre sur sur
l'italienne ça et je peux te dire les
gens pourront prouver que caen reste sur
cette position fait ça pour en baisse 6
maintenant quelles sensations avez il
l'avait clairement préparent ils le
jouent à tempo wade mais alors attention
vous serez prêt alors ça j'ai vu ensuite
à posteriori mais peut-être après des
capitaux propres en d4 21e il a
peut-être cinq cd j'en prends des cas
j'en prendrais 4,275 qui est peut-être
fort mais bon qui prend un sens que
c'est pas cher et si je joue des 5
il accueille des quatre noms en d2 et
donc non tout reprendre et 4 puis on
prend qu'elle prend aurait joué ça dans
une benne à postériori j'ai vu j'ai
juste idée avec 5 quilles des quatre
donc ensuite en réfléchissant j'ai vu ce
type d'acte
en d4 je sais pas du tout comment
j'aurais réagi comme dans la partie mais
je pense que ok même si au pire j'avais
café quai id4 bon là j'aurais quand même
compris et du coup j'aurais par
nécessité jouer pour prendre des quatre
et je pense que ça donne des bonnes
compensation même si j'ai pas là la
preuve écrite mais du fou c'est à peu
près à ce moment là j'étais bien il
n'aime pas penser ça a l'air tellement
lent mais oui ça tiens ça tiens c'est
bien joué
ok donc là aux cinq qui est des casques
et des 4 ouais bon là ok donc j'ai raté
un gain mais oui je n'ai pas du tout vu
ce qui est aussi de dénicher de faire
cet homme et échecs que j'ai pas vu
parce qu'il vient de faire ses six par
un père était mon naturel en fait il
juge que sans la tour b 6
et hélas en fait j'étais très content
par femme de mon train cinquième coup
lancé gt3 sur un court où tu te demandes
ce que tu fais mais oui et en fait
c'était voilà et s'est connecté avec ce
que j'ai fait au 39e ensuite à savoir
dame g6 nam d'être à c'est fini quand
c'est fini
en pratique ce qu'ils nient donc bref
trop mais c'est sûr qu'il prend des cinq
dames prend b3 tu t'en sors peut-être
attendu dire quelle moisson moi ouais
houlette d'un bassiste d'un meurtre
cette chance et j'aurai sans doute pas
prend des simples devraient jouer je ne
sais pas tout re l'aura laissé leur
eczéma mariner quoi ouais c'est ça et
j'ai glissé 4 aussi d'ailleurs
oui oui
club poney 3 to pour le 3 à noter ça
mange pas voilà donc ok et puis après
bon c'est fini je suis dans me2 troncs
des 8es la dernière la dernière partie
tu la verras c'est bien c'est pas
forcément si c'est quand même
intéressant dans le sens où blatter je
suis en mode raw bon alors du coup bon
je change parce que cette fois ci je
veux pas me retrouver dans une prépa et
surtout en bus et puis une ouverture pis
bon camp quand et pas dans l'autre a pas
nécessairement besoin de gagner c'est
pas très agréable à jouer mais là c'est
quand même très différent
et la voilà donc pas rechercher la
passivité obtenir des positions assez
compliqué c'est pas si grave puisque
qu'est ce qu'il va en faire une position
à double tranchant si si c'est pas
agréable à jouer donc là c'est un grave
la joie pour moi tu vois là toutes mes
décisions étaient actives c'est ta pas
du tout l'impression que je suis en mode
raw et c'est ça qui aggrave ouais tu les
archers sûr après c'est plus facile
évident quand tu reviens un peu dure un
peu loin on peut dire du diable vauvert
ouais tu étais dans le domaine bah oui
j'étais dans le dur mais bon mais du
coup tu vas être détendu pour pour la
suite de la compétition quoique tu oui
mais bon après de tout parce qu enfin je
veux dire toujours des moments un peu un
peu plus délicate d'autres dans une
coupe du monde
bon c'est aussi un pas normal que ça
même sourece un peu pour une fois j'ai
envie de venir
ouais c'est que la dernière coupe du
monde on avait laissé c'était était de
l'autre côté du l'autre côté du filet
quoi c'était ton était plutôt en pls
hier on était plutôt fanfaron donc et
puis c'est pire
l armageddon c'était bien c'était
c'était dur c'était dur c'était dur du
coup maxime il te reste donc trois
matches à gagner des parts de ton
de ton objectif juste très rapidement
prochaine adversaire vite l'air ça va
faire sa prophétie bien ouais bon après
notification chaque match est un nouveau
mode donc il va pas venir en victime
expiatoire mais très clairement oui et
c'est toujours sympa un match contre
peter adversaire qui réussit assez bien
voilà puis plus aimé a c'est vrai que
c'est agréable de toute façon les
joueurs à ce niveau sont plutôt gras
boulet puis fair-play donc il y aura pas
de de soucis de ce niveau un ce niveau
là donc on n'aura pas une demande de
dress code qua non à ce niveau là les
joueurs sont fair-play dans l'est c'est
vrai cette histoire de dress code ou pas
ah oui bien sûr ce n'est pas juste
parler il ya c'est donc c'est guéri qui
a demandé parce que ça veut dire ça
fusion que soit soit forfait à cause du
dress code mais il était simple c'était
du troll un bon si tu dois si tu dois tu
dois filer ouest
maxime merci nous avons reçu et a déjà
duré longtemps gardé longtemps à bientôt
bonne chance ciao